it's not supposed to be this way on  Saturday night a speech from Iran's  supreme leader Ayatollah Ali Khamenei is  being carried by the national  broadcaster and then this  [Music]  on-screen revolutionary slogans accuse  Harmony of having blood on his hands  they run for several seconds alongside  pictures of four young women who've died  as protests sweep the nation  those protests have now entered their  fourth week scores have died  Iran has seen protests before but some  say This Time It's Different  this Uprising is much larger in terms of  the scale and much more radical in terms  of the method this Uprising is not about  reform at all it's not about uh economic  grievances also it's about freedom and  democracy  Revolution is in the air it's a  dangerous moment for the regime but it  has put down uprisings before this time  the mood may be different but the result  could still be the same Matthew Thompson  Sky News